Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome to Dungeon Nightmares.
A randomly generated indie horror game that is supposedly excessively scary.
So let's get into it.
"Keep moving, they know where you are."
Whose they, do they need to know where I am?
Am I an important person in this venture?
That's what I need to know and now. Ok.
It is dark, I don't have a flashlight but that says "Press C to use."
And now it says "Press B to blow." Really?
Well, if only life was that easy but we can't always get what we want, you know?
"Help. Me."
It looked like I got kind of a piece of paper, what the hell did I get?
Who the hell am I helping? I'll help ya, and I gotta do is press B to blow if that helps you in any way.
That's my one true -
Oh, what is this, Vanish? Don't blow steam in my face.
Ok, I got a map here. Ok, well that's nice. At least it shows me exactly where I went.
This candle doesn't do jack doodly squat! I can't - oh.
Ah, whatever. It was nothing.
Ok, I got the volume way turned way up in my headphones
and I got my pants way turned down on my legs, I guess, if that made any sense.
And I'm ready to go. Come on, bring on the scares.
What is that? Oh, that's a fly?
Is it a fly that's gonna buzz and burrow into my ear like in that other game that I just played?
Don't Let Go? Probably not.
K, I hear flies. Why would there be flies unless there were dead bodies just rotting openly in the floor?
Which there probably will be. Just sayin'.
Just super saiyan.
Ok, this is a dead end but I'm gonna explore everything.
This reminds me a lot of Dreadhalls and I apologize, my voice is a little raspy toda -
"She's coming!" Do I need to press B to blow?
I'm just - I'm curious! If you - if you need me to - 'cause that's my one skill, that's the only thing I can do right now.
So, uh...I got another candle. That's good.
Oh, my candle went out! I didn't even get to blow it!
So these candles seriously do not help me much at all. Can I run, yes I can run.
That's good, that'll be useful for running away like a big bubble blowing baby.
Candle. Oh what, no secret message on that chest? You told me strange things on the other one.
[loud sound]
Ok! Silence is good, too!
Riiiight, ok. So, uh...what was that all about?
Ooh, I like the atmosphere in this game. I been pretty lucky because there's been some good horror - uh OH!
Hi? I - wha - are you just a statue?
Hi! I'm gonna call you Boney! You want me to press B to blow?
You want me to press B to bo - blow Boney?
Ok, whatever.
Paper. "I wouldn't look in the mirror." Where's the mirror?
AH Fffuhuhuck you, dickbag! Motherhumper! Assbaghole!
You just lost your B to blow privileges!
Who's that? Was that someone over there? How am I supposed to finish -
No, what, where'd it go?
The skeleton - oh, he's over there. He's a-running!
Oh, there's the dead body splayed out on the floor, rotting for everyone to see.
Huah! Ok, alright.
[distant woman's voice]
(high pitched) Oh no!
Someone complaining about something over there?
'Cause I would like to say that my problems seem to be a bit more significant than yours.
Or maybe you're being murdalized, I dunno.
"Don't trust anyone you meet down here."
Oh, I was gonna trust Boney! I was about to B to blow him but it didn't work out too well, 'cause he was being a bit of a douche.
So I'm gonna D to...douche him, I dunno. I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm just trying to make stupid jokes, that's all I do. I'm just a dumb YouTuber who plays video games.
To some awesome fans, probably the best fans in the world. Handsome AND beautiful in every way.
Nah, but seriously, we just hit 2.2 million, uh, subscribers recently, I'm gonna make a vlog on Monday,
but...you guys have been absolutely amazing to me, I mean,
that's 2.2 million after just hitting 2 million about, I dunno, two and a half weeks ago,
the growth has just been startlingly huge, and just thank you guys so much for, uh, enjoying my videos, I really do appreciate it.
I didn't even read what that said.
[clunk]
IS THERE SOMETHING BEHIND ME?!
Was that a guillotine going over my head?
Ok, no. Alright, come on. I got places to be, I got things to do, I'm out of candles.
Ack, god, I need more candles, I'm gonna run out very soon.
I'm going down this place to the staircase -
Hi steam, I was more worried about Boney over there.
Are you the same Boney as the other Boney? I gotta turn around to open this door.
HUVAJERRR!
[heartbeat]
Kayyyy? That's interesting!
I was so hideously ugly that the second I looked at him...he DIED.
I was so ugly that everyone died!
Maybe that's why there's all these dead bodies! I just walked through and everyone just died.
"Day 4, it's so cold at night, need to find more candles."
Yes, I agree, it's about to get darker in here. Not that the candles do much, but it's better than nothing.
Maybe it's not better than nothing. Maybe -
[ROAR]
Are you kidding me?! What the hell was that?!
Nah, you come back here, you bitch, you don't get away that easily!
You say that to my face! Even though you did and you sprayed your spit everywhere.
But I can spray spit as an equal - volume?
What's this? That's a book.
"Artifact found," it was a book, not an artifact! "Find the exit"?
Well, how? What do I do, is it all the way down there?
I'm gonna assume it's all the way at the end. 'Cause that would be the proper thing to do.
Uhh, it's dark! Am I going the right way? I gotta keep double checking.
Ah, what is that? What am - why am I picking up gold bars?
This is, um...this does remind me a lot of Dreadhalls, maybe it's - maybe it's like this is Dreadhalls but in a different version of it.
'Cause Dreadhalls was originally -
WHYAMIARERURAGH?
WHYAMIREARGGH
Why, what? Who what hi. You!
I'm gonna stare at you until you die! Or I'm gonna - or I'm gonna NYEAH!
Or I'm gonna NYEAH! Come on. Let's - let's be serious, here.
Ha, let's be serious here, I'm almost outta candle, I really gotta get outta here.
You behind me? Ok. Ah, wait a minute!
I wanna see if - like, what is the conditions in which these guys move?
Turning around...OH! Hi, ok.
And that is the Slenderman noise, I could - I recognize it.
You know where I sleep? You know I sleep in my bed! No! How could you!
Ok. Anyway. "Don't let her find you."
Her? Was that the glimpse of the someone that I thought I -
UUEAH I CAN'T MOVE!
Uh oh! Ok, speeding up now. Come on! Come on!
Come on! I'm almost at the exit, I think.
Ah, the exit! Yeah, buddy!
[buzzing]
Alright! Fly, get outta my ear, get outta my ear! I got places to be.
Whoo! That - that was a lot like Dreadhalls.
Except no. Night 1?! It said there were 7 nights.
God! How long is this game gonna take to beat?
"You woke up in 6 minutes and 50 seconds." Thank you, I know. I'm great.
Wow, I found a lot of the stuff! I'm very surprised!
Let's see what night 2 is like 'cause I'm ready for another.
"The dungeon grows stronger."
Well, the first one wasn't very strong to begin with, so I don't know about that.
"Night 2 awaits."
This is surprising, there's like, usually with these experiences it's like one, done.
Let's go again. "Press space to start night 2."
"They only move when you don't see them."
Why, 'cause they're embarrassed? I would be.
Ok, so, night 2. Things get stronger, supposedly.
"Don't follow her to that room."
Oh really? Did she hear about my B to blow skills? She wants me to follow her to a roo -
[growling]
Nah, nah nah nah. Nah, you get outta here with that noise.
Come on, bring it on!
Mmm, ok. Uhh. The atmosphere in this game is great.
It's got some really rock solid jump scares. I mean, the skeleton mechanic has been done before, but still.
It's not bad. Can't complain.
And I really wanna know what - what's with - I only caught a glimpse of like, another person
and, I'm assuming that's that lady they keep talking about.
Ok. Oh, god, this one looks fun! And by fun, I mean horrible.
It's usually - die?! I picked up a piece of paper and you tell me to die?! Isn't that a little extreme here?
[scream]
AHH HUHU WHOA!
You - buwaaghgahg! You wanna explain what just happened to me?
I - a lady passed through me and I felt a shudder down my spine!
What was it? What why was it? Am I following her to that room? I don't think so, I don't know so.
Ok. Ok. Oh, that was a good one. That was a good one.
This game has been - ok, that's backtracking.
This game has, uh, been pretty good with, like, keeping me on edge.
And mixing things up. I like it a lot!
Yeah, like I said, this was originally develped for iOS, I believe.
Nothing in there. Oh, that's a nice painting.
Another gold bah!
I sure am glad that I'm focused on treasures in this time of...dire peril.
I mean, a gold bar that size would be like worth what, a couple hundred thousand dollars?
[loud sound]
What, why why why?!
What whywhywhywhywhywhywhy?
[loud sound]
UHH! Whywhywhywhywhay!
What'd you do to me? Why? Why do I keep blacking out -
AAAHAHAH!
You son of a bitch! You little dickbag!
Oh, hi! I didn't even know you were there!
You get outta here, you fall over and die, you douche.
[music escalates]
Boney? Hello?
[scream]
AAAHHH! AHH, OK!
[screechy chase music]
I get it, I get it, you don't want me in here!
I get it, you don't want me stealing your...very good treasures.
Ok. Ok, she's still there! She's still there, she's following me!
That's a dead end! I can't move! WHY CAN'T I MOVE?!
GAAADAGDADAGAH!
OPEN THE DAMN DOOR! OOH SHE'S GONNA KILL ME!
AHH, SHE'S GONNA KILL ME!
AH, WHERE AM I GOING?
OH GOD, oh I'm in a dead end!
Stop with the noise! Stop with the noise! Close the damn door!
Uhhh!
[chase music fades]
(wheezes) Good god! Are you kidding me?
What the hell! Hoh! That was the most panic-inducing chase I've had for a long time!
Whoa, nelly! You need to tone it down!
This is only night 2!
Just wait till we get to the third date, baby! I'll let you get to...fifth base.
And score a home touchdown on me. If you know what I mean.
[heavy breathing]
Oh, that's me running out of sprint juice, ok, I get it, I get it now.
I'm with it. I'm down to clown. Until we're all dead in the ground.
Which might be very very soon here.
K. Alright.
[steam hisses]
Shut up! Was that steam or was that something else, I have no idea.
Oh! Well, there's the exit.
But what good does that do me, I don't have anything for it yet.
(phone vibrates)
Excuse me, can you shut up?
I am in the middle of something. I just got a text, I don't know if you could hear it.
[scraping sounds]
No! No, I know that sound! Well I don't know it, but I know it means bad!
(scared noises)
Hello. I'm in here. I'm - I'm where the sound I heard was. Got something for me?
How the hell am I gonna find this damn artifact?
"The darkness know has you." Oh, it does, does it?
How does it have me? In what way? Oh no, please darkness, don't get me.
Oh no, don't make me B to blow! If you know what I mean.
I think everyone knows what I mean at this point.
"No one can hear you scream down there." I'm pretty sure hundreds of thousands of people can hear me scream.
Ok.
Ok. Oh - ooh. Oh hi, Boney.
Hey Boney, you've lost your privileges, you get outta here. Is there anything else in here? Is there even -
Where am I? Ok. I'm gonna back out slowly, of this room, and go this way.
I don't think there was a chest in there but I may have missed it.
God, I keep - I keep running out of sprint meter-ness. I need to concentrate and focus, I'm gonna beat this.
Or else I'm gonna die. Those are my two options, pretty much.
Ah, where is this damn -
[music escalates]
Hi lady! Ah, you so pretty. I'm outta candles. Could you gimme some?
I can't see a damn thing. A dead end, alright.
Let's get outta here. Oh man, I'm gonna have to loop all the way back to the exit once I find this ding dong damn artifact!
Why does anyone care about a book, I got giant...bars of gold.
You get outta here.
[loud sound]
GUH you get outta here with that noise!
You get - AH you get outta here with that noise!
Bing! Red light.
Green light! Oh, opposite. Green light.
Green light.
Red light!
(laughs) Get outta here! You get outta here! Nyeah!
Mnyeah! Nyear raar. Nyear. Narrar!
Rarr! This isn't me B to blowing you, you get outta here, I'm just moving you 'cause I need to get to this door.
Oh, what's that! Ok. You say something? Ok.
What's going on? Ok.
No, no. I don't want any company right now so you go eff off.
(laughs) Aw! He still wanted to play!
Ah! How'd you get through that door?
Get a candle now. Wait no, I got a candle?
Ah! Now I'm gonna - now you're gonna get it. Now you might get it.
I don't know why I'm looking in the chests for the artifact, it was uh, on a shelf before.
Yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah, you get outta here. Byyyyye!
Have fun at school in hell! Have fun in hell-school.
You know what I mean. I'm telling you subtly to go to hell.
God, where is this thing?
Oh, I found it! Yay! I can move on now! (laughs)
Let's get outta here. Oh, come on! Stop sprinting for two meters and then dying of breath loss.
Ok. So if I, uh, go straight down here, slightly to the right.
You know that red text, when it says artifact is found makes me think that I might die soon.
[scream]
I might die soon!
[whisper: "I will always be with you."]
No thank you!
["Always."]
I need some personal space! If you don't mind!
Okie dokie, I'm outta here. I'm so outta here! I'm not down to clown with you.
Ok. Alright, don't sprint so much, calmly walk, there is no crisis.
AH! WHY IS THERE A CRISIS! WHY IS THERE A CRISIS NOW?!
Why suddenly was there a crisis?! Where am I - I'm going the wrong way! No, I'm going the right way.
What happened! Is this some -
[loud sound]
AH! Uuuhh!
Get - OHH NO!
Bad time to run out of sprint! I'm gonna B to blow you.
(blows) And then I'm gonna get outta here.
Whee! Alright, you son of a bitch. (laughs)
Ok. So there you have it. "Night 2 survived."
Hmm. It makes me wonder, 'cause there are 5 more nights, how am I gonna do this?
Like, this is getting a bit more...complicated.
Hm, I wonder - I wonder...I wonder if I should do a second part of this.
Hmm, alright, ok. I'll do it this way, 'cause it's been - I've been playing for about 17 minutes,
there's no way I'm gonna get through all 7.
"They want their revenge"? Well, they can come get a piece of me later, if you guys want it.
So, either way, leave a like to let me know if you want me to complete 3 through 7,
this is actually not a bad horror game here, it's actually kinda fun.
I wonder what new and interesting stuff awaits me on the other nights, but either way.
Write a comment, leave a like, thank you all so much for watching.
And also, um, I don't know if I've ever mentioned it, but if you guys want to, please follow me on Facebook and Twitter,
there are links down in the description, you can keep up to date on other stuff that's going on, like...
...uh, secret projects that I'm working with, with collab-ing with other people and livestreams that go on in the...
...in the darkness that you guys don't already know about, so either way,
just gimme a follow or a like if you want to. Thank you all so much for watching, and as always,
I will see YOU in the next video.
Bye-bye!